all right guys bang-bang I've got Matt
here we've got a lot to get through I
appreciate you doing this from from
quarantine yeah great to see for sure
all right let's jump right in why don't
you go through your background and how
you eventually got into Bitcoin ether in
crypto and then we'll jump into some of
the stuff you're working on yeah you got
it um so I joined the space in 2013 I
built this little app I'm you know I'm
gonna take you through it I was working
on a start-up and I was trying to make
rent and I was like looking around what
can I sell in my house and one of the
things I had was this stack of Starbucks
cards and I kinda I realized like not
only could I sell these like I don't
really drink Starbucks but I bet I could
buy all my friends unused cards and of
course not only did I do that
then I built an app around it and I
partnered with a local coffee shop to
buy all these I'm used Starbucks cards
and start making rent and so I turned
that into a an early Bitcoin project way
back when called cart for coin calm and
we would just fire Starbucks carts for
60 cents on the dollar and and this is
the funny thing I wasn't really in
crypto but I was trying to build this
site and PayPal was like oh gift cards
no we're not gonna we're not gonna play
with that and so that's what got me into
Bitcoin I actually had to solve my own
problem and so you know I got down the
rabbit hole card for coin calm became
another another product actually I think
you've had on fold with wool reefs so
eventually that that grew and spun out
into its own thing but since then you
know I'm a technologist but I believe in
money crypto so after after working
unfold I started trying to solve
problems like what if I could
decentralize these gift card
marketplaces what if I could you know
getting kind of fancy and I went through
all the stuff on Bitcoin like Omni back
in the day and kind of all the second
layer toys looked at stuff like
open Bazaar and eventually I actually
started playing early 2017 with
aetherium so I think like it heart I'm
still a Bitcoin er I got into the space
for the censorship resistant money and
and open finance eventually like I've
always been a libertarian but eventually
I became kind of a money crypto person
as well but I still like to build cool
things and a lot of that means playing
with other chance very cool and so you
describe yourself as kind of a monetary
maximalist which i think is a really
interesting way to describe a point of
view maybe explain what exactly does
that mean yeah yeah so I think today
when people say Bitcoin maximalist that
can mean all sorts of things depending
on who's saying it right like it's a
badge of honor for some and it's kind of
like a troll for other it's kind of
mixed but there's this like partisanship
around it that maybe sometimes goes
beyond just the asset like sometimes
it's about the tech and it's about being
surrounded by all these crappy scams
right I think I think it's a little
overboard so for me Bitcoin the asset
that's our shot at taking on central
banks and taking on the status quo
Bitcoin the technology is legacy and
it's great it's great legacy it's kept
running you know all these years and
that's what you need out of a strong
hard money layer is stability but the
the the newest scalability and privacy
improvements aren't happening on Bitcoin
anymore so that's kind of why I say man
Monetary Maximus I'm okay applying with
aetherium and sea cash and places where
I think the tech is interesting but
ultimately my goal is still going to be
coming back to Bitcoin the asset got it
and so there's a very hotly debated and
in to the point of controversial
viewpoint and I basically break it down
into two components right you have sound
money in Bitcoin but all of the
infrastructure surrounding that
historically has been centralized and
then you've got on the other side in a
kind of ether dphi role you have
decentralized infrastructure but then
you have this asset that's kind of
masquerading as money but probably
doesn't
same sound money principles that Bitcoin
has right and so it feels like there's a
mismatch between centralized and
decentralized infrastructure sound money
and not somebody you are taking the
approach okay and very Bitcoin and defy
together describe your kind of viewpoint
and how you plan to do that and then we
could talk about the reverse of you know
why not bring defy to Bitcoin
yeah sure so I mean I think you've
nailed it right the I think it's for so
long in Bitcoin we've only had
centralized alternatives and a lot of
the stuff open Bazaar is an example that
tried to go to the next level and take
to centralization to the next level it
was it was so difficult to use and we
look at things like bisque for example
it's just very little very little
real-world usage today but then you know
I'll say even a little bit more about
etherium they there's a huge cultural
divide so it's not just that ether isn't
the same sound money as Bitcoin it's
that a lot of people working etherium
don't care there's sort of like a
left-right like optimist versus
conservative thing going on and you know
as someone who was in Bitcoin as an
engineer I wanted to do all the things
people were doing with theorem but just
with Bitcoin there was no reason for me
to add another asset so when I'm talking
to folks who came to the space aetherium
first I tell them like all this Keith is
money stuff like cut that that's not a
useful find your own narrative for
either Bitcoin is money
maybe ether will be like gas or fuel or
something else but the tech is is
interesting so what we've done is a
project called T BTC and the idea is
that we're building this bridge that I
hope is going to be a bridge between the
communities as well as the technology
and the assets so we'll bring Bitcoin
onto aetherium it's one to one backed
it's always redeemable so you never have
some token on the theorem that you can't
immediately get back to Bitcoin on l14
and then we maintain sound money and
inflation ship resistance we maintain
censorship resistance so there's no big
coin Bank in the middle that's kind of
like printing tokens on the etherium
side got it and so maybe walk us through
exactly how TV TC work strikes I think a
lot of people know Oh TV TC is the idea
of how do we bring Bitcoin to defy but
like how does that actually work yeah so
it's it's taking the idea of sidechains
that we've been playing with since
2013-2014 and kind of iterating a little
bit right so in Bitcoin I think the
closest we've had with any commercial
success to a sidechain with something
like liquid and the basic idea is you
take Bitcoin and you trust a 15-member
multi-sig so you put your Bitcoin in
that multi-sig and then the members of
that multi-sig run another chain based
on the Bitcoin that you put in so that's
called a federated peg and it's like a
step it's better than just putting your
Bitcoin in exchange right but at the end
of the day you're trusting a majority of
the signers to like be good guys and
really if they just walk with your
Bitcoin there's no recourse except for
legal right which is like when I hear
that for a bit corner oh just sue them
I'm like oh guys why are we building in
this space if that's the answer right so
our model is a little bit different we
take this Federation and we make that
the first step but instead of having a
federation for the whole economy every
single deposit
gets a new micro Federation so every
time you say you know I want to move one
Bitcoin on to aetherium we put together
a new randomly chosen Federation of
signers and then the other piece is that
we use SPB proofs which have been around
since Satoshi so it's the basic idea is
that you can prove when you move Bitcoin
you can prove that on the etherium chain
and so because you do that you can
actually set and look I move Bitcoin
into the system and you can successfully
print TBT see the last part is
redeemable ability so this is the part
where if you're using system like liquid
you have to hope like please guys send
me back my Bitcoin but in our system if
the if the Federation doesn't send you
back your Bitcoin you slash them so they
can put down ether or they can
down us DT or other collateral types and
if they don't do what you ask is the
positive way their money so it kind of
removes the reputation component yeah
got it
and so do you see this first being
valuable for developers or for users and
what I mean by that is there's a lot of
technical challenges with integrating
Bitcoin into D Phi you guys are building
a lot of those bridges you're trying to
kind of break down those barriers or
obstacles is this a let's solve the
developers problem and then consumers
follow or is it the opposite consumers
want this and developers will build
around it yeah so I'm trying to tackle
both right so like build it and they
will come it's nonsense like if you just
build things for developers and
developers don't show up users won't
won't use it like what is their use so
so our go-to-market is you know we
focused heavily on integrations early
most of the major defy platforms will
support us out the gate so you can get
leverage you can start lending out your
Bitcoin borrowing against it earning it
will be a safe way to make yield other
as an alternative to things like block
Phi on the one hand right and that'll be
immediately available but on the other
hand we're also empowering devs who care
about things like privacy products to
build on Bitcoin on aetherium so that's
really like my heart of hearts what I
really want to see is fungibility solved
if aetherium is like reason to exist is
as a fungibility layer for Bitcoin and a
place to experiment for Bitcoin then we
want got it and what are the initial use
cases that you see people kind of going
after are there specific products or
yeah these use cases more about you're
gonna give it to the you know give it to
the world and let them figure out what
to do with it
no I mean you know what I'm most excited
about this is just totally my life so
like I have a couple kids we moved back
we were in California for maybe four
years and we move it back and decided to
buy a house in Georgia and my wife said
you know it's time it's time to sell
your Bitcoin and I just laughed like I
am not selling crypto
to buy a house like I would rather take
take a mortgage and keep it and so but I
did look into it right and this was kind
of before we have loaned us now but this
was before we had loaned us so I heard
oh there's a lender down the street who
loves Bitcoin and that I was introduced
to so I went to talk to him and they
said yeah we do love Bitcoin it's so
great that you came in and sell your
Bitcoin come back in 30 days and we'll
pretend we never talked about this and
I'm like I'm not trying to avoid taxes
here guys
I just I mean I am but like I'm not
trying to like launder money you don't
need to like you know it's not hidden
that I have Bitcoin I just I I want to
be able to take a loan I got against my
Bitcoin is collateral so one of the
things that I think about crypto is it
sort of millennial money right so now
the answer is well there are all these
lenders that will will accept Bitcoin as
collateral okay if you are a high enough
net worth individual that's true but
like I shouldn't have to ask anyone and
so what I would like to see TV TC for is
taking stable coin loans out immediately
against my Bitcoin and accessing the
equity while still holding my BTC not
disposing of it so that's my goal
it should be good to go four to six
weeks after TBT sees launch and then in
the meantime there are tons of places to
earn yield for example compound is
integrated with TB PC on test net right
now check it out
got it and so one of the things that I
think you believe but correct me if I'm
wrong is that moving Bitcoin into the
defy world is a massive inflection point
of growth for defy right this idea that
like TB TC can help to inflate the size
and kind of engagement in defy one is
that true and then to if it is maybe
describe a little bit about how you
think that through yeah yes so I mean I
look at you know the market cap numbers
are changing every day but a hundred one
hundred and forty billion dollars give
or take in Bitcoin right now and you
know 12 or 14 in aetherium and so for me
that's like Bitcoin is super collateral
and defy runs on collateral it's not
about
our allies loans it's about taking
different positions against different
assets and if you're building a
decentralized lending platform and you
haven't brought in the best collateral
possible clearly you're missing out but
I also think that it's going to be big
for Bitcoin and I think that's a little
understated so obviously like d-phi
needs more collateral and that's a big
45 but I think Bitcoin wants utility I
think we have the technology for it and
can prevent this can prevent minors from
meeting to sell because they'll be able
to take loans out against their Bitcoin
after it's minted actually they can even
keep they can even keep their new
Bitcoin so they don't need to lose that
premium that you get on freshly minted
coins and it'll kind of let us like
actually like not just stick it under
our mattress but make Bitcoin more part
of our lives on top of the store value
it has now got it and so you have taken
the approach of how do we bring Bitcoin
and that sound money to the defy world
the other option would have been how do
we bring the decentralized
infrastructure to Bitcoin maybe talk a
little bit about the trade-offs between
those two decisions and you chose to go
the path you chose yeah so honestly
going the other way it's just it's tough
so so the either way I have to get into
some serious low-level Bitcoin
development like we're the guys who are
hurt in there and and messing around
with squibbed and odd transaction types
and kind of all the stuff that you hear
people have been playing with Bitcoin
for a long time will talk about but
going the other way is difficult for two
reasons so one is that this defy
ecosystem already exists so if you look
at something like like a root stock or a
project that's try to go the other
direction they've got all the additional
work of meaning to build the ecosystem
and I think that's a huge lift and
related to that is just standardization
so suddenly you need to come up with
like how are these things going to
interoperate how are we not going to
split your liquidity all over the place
how can we keep this all together so I
think there I think there are two
directions one is the tech is very hard
going the other direction a lot of the
tools that a theorem developers are used
to are maybe three steps in abstract
above what we can do in Bitcoin today
and then on the other side just like
that's where the users are and
ultimately I think that I think that
there are going to be more users from
both systems combined then I think
they're going to be from either
individually so that's kind of my take
is like yes we'll be bringing some
bitcoiners into this new tech but we'll
also be bringing more people into
Bitcoin than weren't there before got it
that makes sense
and do you think that in the future even
though it's hard to bring the
decentralized infrastructure to Bitcoin
will kind of have both decisions end up
being brought to reality meaning we'll
bring Bitcoin to d5 will also bring defy
to Bitcoin and it's just two different
types of projects two different types of
teams and over a long time horizon be
there or do you think it's really really
hard so so with like my full effect what
if I'm trying to like troll and etherion
I'd say like Bitcoin was the first defy
we don't need to bring defy to Bitcoin
you know you guys are the ones that want
the collateral and bitcoins doing just
fine by itself so now but but I think
the question is like do the two
technical approaches kind of net out and
I think that at the end of the day
bitcoins reason to exist is to move
slowly and safely and aetherium doesn't
have that culture for better or worse
and the upside of that is we can build
things very quickly and the downside is
the stability is not there to nearly the
same degree as a Bitcoin so I do think
that I think that Bitcoin will win for
the monetary premium but I actually
think that the move a little bit faster
than Bitcoin dev cycle will probably win
more users in the interim I could be
wrong
we've we've obviously seen I'm a huge
lightning fan we've obviously seen
uptake enlightening people are starting
to use liquid lightly but I think you
have to ask yourself do I want to do I
want to trust 15 people or 2000 when I'm
using a system like this and and what's
my risk for sure
Vitalik recently tweeted basically
saying that we needed something like
this maybe talk a little
but about what he said and I'm kind of
you know your reaction to seeing that
yeah yeah so I mean he said he said a
couple things there's a lot to unpack so
you know he said that he wanted to see
it Bitcoin aetherium bridge but he also
said that he wanted to see a Bitcoin
aetherium decks and the funny thing
about that is I want to build what the
market wants and I think what the market
wants is stronger collateral and I think
the market wants Bitcoin I don't think
what the market wants is going from BTC
to eat faster or more smoothly and so
that might just be my bias against ethos
an asset but I just see like you know
maker needs more collateral
it doesn't need faster BTC eat the swaps
I like to think we're solving a half is
problem that makes sense
are there other projects that you see
working on some more things that you're
like you know what that's cool and in
something we're either you get to work
with them in the future we need to be
other solutions yeah of course I mean I
think if you want to take the other side
of the bet which is that Bitcoin on the
theorem is cool but you don't need to
centralization at all then WBT see where
bitcoin can app or bit coax is the
Bitcoin bank you know it's interesting I
haven't seen the extreme interest that I
would hope I think I've also seen some
stuff around like hash rate derivatives
and more decentralized minor products
which I'm really excited about because
you know eventually you can imagine a
world where there is a crackdown even
further than there has been on mining
and I'd like to see like how can you how
can you still run a large mining farm
and get the whole thing financed if your
government is against you right and so I
think we're gonna see some really
interesting products there crap cropping
up as well and you know kind of just
working in general you're in Georgia a
coronavirus is running rant around the
world
you know is really interesting to me how
crypto has been built in a decentralized
kind of remote way for years now and it
seems like most teams are having new
disruptions for the most part are you
guys seeing any disruptions or is it
kind of business as usual for you um
look times are different this is a big
thing and it impacts everyone whether or
not you're a remote team so like I have
a family they're you know my kids
grandparents I'm not comfortable with
them watching my kids I don't want my
grandparents my parents to get sick I
think you know so we are a remote first
team and we're not a team like coinbase
where it's just a whole bunch of people
in one spot in San Francisco we're
globally distributed it doesn't impact
us nearly as much as other teams but I
think like the human aspect is still
there so a lot of us in crypto we have
so many friends globally that we knew
like I knew people in Wuhan when the
outbreak first happened I was deciding
whether or not to go Satoshi roundtable
because some friends got stuck in Wuhan
and we had to be like isn't he been safe
and that was what February 6th so I
think I guess to answer your question
the company's in a good spot but we're
all having to deal with you know worried
for our families and and whatnot and I
also think that at least for me I had a
brief heart attack with that early
Bitcoin drop I think I I think this is
an opportunity for us to really show the
world what we're made of and it does
just have to be the ticker right it also
needs to be like let's actually deliver
deliver products that help people
through this time I think that I'm when
we kind of wake up from this disaster
and and from the hangover from all the
free money and all of the attempts at
fixing the economy we need the crypto
needs to be there and be ready to
onboard the next you know billion users
and so so that's kind of my take it's
like this is unfortunate this is
impacting everyone but it's also the
best time for us to build and get
something out for sure that makes a ton
of sense let's talk about that drop I
was
sitting there like everyone else
watching and it just kept falling and
falling and falling is one of those
situations you're like I I think I'm
gonna go 2-0 with this thing but like
damn this is happening really fast and
this scares me
what were you thinking how that's going
on what's going through your head I mean
I was gobbling up cheap coins if I'm
being honest I am I have this thing in
my life where on the one hand I want to
have dry powder so I can buy the dip but
on the other hand I hate having any non
crypto at any time so like it's a tough
it's a tough trade yeah I mean I think
when we when we went below 4 that's when
I briefly was like whole like maybe I
made a mistake but you know I you know I
remember when gosh like things were
really bleak through 2014 and 2015 and
and we got through that just fine
it just it always takes longer it never
it never happens when you want it to and
the market doesn't care about your
holdings or your position right now but
eventually eventually I think it's clear
that this is this is a good bet and so
so I guess I'm like a perma Bowl a
little bit I try to not give people like
people are like should I buy and my
answer is always yes you should never
ask me for trading advice but um but
yeah so that was it that was my take and
the other thing is like honestly I try
to take little pleasure when people get
washed out because with that
deleveraging and with that bit max
cascade some people who were in the
space for the wrong reasons got wrecked
and okay like I'm sorry guys he lost
money but also more for the rest of us
yeah I think one of the really
interesting things with Nick Carter and
the coin metrics team they did this
analysis and they basically showed that
most of the coins that were being sold
were had been moved in the last six
months but pretty much nobody who was a
long-term holder was selling and so when
you start to look at that it's the
strong hands aren't going to get shaken
out I don't care what happens to the
price that's right that's right yeah I
mean the only way I sell us if I think
I'm gonna get more Bitcoin out of it you
know so um yeah that's kind of my take
very cool what do you think it's the
most important company in crypto outside
of what you guys working on cool
good question well actually you've
excluded us I get that so I'm a huge fan
of and and a co-founder so I'm gonna say
I think fold is quite important but it's
a bit I you know I think it's I think
it's really important to let people get
into crypto in a way that's not scary a
way to earn into crypto rather than on
be like bet their life savings owner and
so anything where people are shopping
and they're immediately seeing discounts
you know airline miles don't matter
anymore and Bitcoin does so I I love
seeing like SATs back programs so after
fold I think I think lolly is really
interesting I think block fly anything
that lets us start earning and stacking
rather than spending and I also think
like one of the things that I love about
the space is this kind of counter
consumerism like if we all believe that
long term number will go up you should
not spend money right now and we should
delay gratification and I actually think
that's a great antidote for sort of the
state of American consumerism you know
so so anyway so I'm a huge fan of
savings apps and that's on the kind of
like onboarding side I think I'll stick
with that there's a lot of cool
infrastructure being built but like at
the end of the day I think what
convinced this people to join the space
is the most important what's your most
controversial thought in the space and
what do you believe that everyone else
will disagree with you on oh man
well I've got a couple so so as you can
imagine like my old like Bitcoin friends
hate me and my new aetherium friends
hate me and so I sort of regret the
fence of no one wants to have me at a
party because I'm gonna piss everyone
off but getting more specific so like on
the Bitcoin side I don't think this
matters but I ultimately have a problem
with the cap I I think that we need to
be really honest that now it might be
five having's from now
in which case I don't care you know but
um but that eventually we need to
consider a better way to pay for
security it doesn't have to be the cap
moving and I think the strength of the
meme is more important than what will
actually happen when we eventually have
to deal with it but that got me a pretty
big slapping around in the Bitcoin
community last year I think I think on
the etherium side just the fact that I
stay aetherium the technology but not
ether the asset is infuriating to a lot
of people but they have this funny thing
so like the Bitcoin community right is
is like they have this like social
immune system where if they don't like
what you're doing and you don't really
prove yourself like you're a scammer
there's just sort of like a like a
hierarchy of things you go down and it's
and it works it works very well to to
remove bad actors from the community
early put on the etherium side they're
incredibly tolerant and so there's this
paradox of tolerance where if you have
like a heterodox opinion in etherium
they still invite you to all their
things and try to take you very
seriously and be nice and so I think
when I say you know I believe in the
tech but not the asset it really it
really bugs them those are two highly
controversial opinions so usually
disappointing yeah Frost
what's the most important book you've
ever read oh man oh god you're asking a
good one um okay so so I wanted to be a
writer for a long time
and it was either a writer or a computer
scientist so I went on this deep dive
through like through the beat poets and
existentialism and I got into some
Russian stuff big fan of Russian
literature but I still think there's a
book by Jack Kerouac that I think a lot
of people would really frown on even
that I would mention him but uh but it
was called the Subterraneans
and I think he got like super high I
think it was like on mescaline and just
like wrote this thing
and love it's beautiful and so I think I
know the right answer would be this like
cool not money in the state and whatever
but like actually it's just a beautiful
book he I don't know I'm a great writer
but it definitely gets to you so uh so
yeah Subterraneans by Jack Kerouac
probably top of mind and then if we're
getting to like other stuff you know I
mean I don't know just like let's name
all the cool sovereign individual things
that's probably good for my personal
brand or whatever so before I finish up
and let you ask me one question I
normally ask people about aliens but
you've got a dinosaur sitting over your
shoulder back there you gotta tell me
the the story of the dinosaur and then
believer in dinosaurs or are you one of
these people who believes they are not
real
nope all right got your back
juggling here okay all right no we're
all good let me ask the dinosaur
question again we'll go from there got
five minutes probably left yeah shoot so
you've got a dinosaur back over your
shoulder and only ask people about
aliens you gotta tell me the story the
dinosaur and then believer or
non-believer that a dinosaurs are real
so some of my son definitely believes in
dinosaurs he was a pterodactyl picture
day a few days ago at school or not
after a few weeks ago at this point with
this quarantine but um but yeah you know
what I believe in dinosaurs I do not
think that God just left fossils for us
to find I do believe in dinosaurs Anna
and I will say I also believe in aliens
I think the world is too interesting for
aliens do not exist I hope that the
various paradoxes about how far away
they are and the speed of light will be
resolved somehow and my my descendants
will be able to meet them so I love it
I am a I'm a believer in dinosaurs as
well I'm with you I don't think that
it's possible that they could be fake
but uh got a couple of friends who say I
never seen one so I don't believe in
them which always gives me a good laugh
I don't think that's really good science
one question you have for me too to wrap
this up what do I need to do to convince
you to move 10% of your Bitcoin on to
aetherium well I think I've said on a
podcast before I have no control over
anything I was super worried a long time
ago
and so basically took a lot of kind of
security steps to to not have any
control so first I would have to have
some conversations but second is on top
of that I think it's a market decides
thing like you probably know there's
more than most but the whole idea of
like compounding trust almost
it's like as the market determines a
winner I think that then you get the
flywheel spinning and so what I always
say is developers are actually probably
going to be the first to use something
like this but as users and what I mean
by that is they understand the technical
components they can actually underwrite
the the safety the security the risks
etc much better than someone who's
non-technical and so as you see some of
them move over and start using it I
think then that's when that flywheel
really starts and then you start to see
people say hey you know what I am you
know I'm in to do this try it and kind
of continue using it totally well for
the rest of you if you want to be an
early adopter it's TBT cidade network
come check it out we'll be announcing
main net in a couple weeks and the other
thing is that if in the meantime if you
don't want to move all your Bitcoin to
etherium but you want to make some money
help us build that bridge get involved
it's permissionless after all for sure
TBT seed network is the website where
else can people find you guys online so
I mean we have all sorts that we've got
maybe 30 brands but just hit me up on
Twitter it's image Luongo TBT see it on
network will tell you a bit about that
project we've got another one keep that
network we're all over the place so if
you just google Bitcoin on aetherium I
imagine we'll be top 3 check us out
also gotta get you two top one right you
can't can't have other people beat you I
know I love it all right Matt listen I
really appreciate jumping on and doing
this I think people really gonna enjoy
it I hope so talk to you soon